no okay here it is all right
so yesterday
as you guys know i was uh
talking and we were watching the origins
of uh
reverend tracy g who we believe is a
super villain in the making
and we went through her 2011 to 2017
background well today we will be going
through her
um
we'll be going through her current phase
we're going to 2000 we're going to 2017
through uh let's see here
2019 all right so let's check her out
let's pull her up and let's see
what we can figure out
so oh i went to the fort vancouver
uh canada that makes sense uh van mall
uh location
and um you know i've always
felt uncomfortable there i just the p
i just always felt uncomfortable there
well i was there
and i had to make copies for some
dumb thing for social services and i
knew i was going to be spending about 10
20 dollars there making copies
and i i had five dollars in cash i was
gonna use that before i use my debit
card
okay so i'm making copies i spent all my
five dollars making copies just copy
this copy not just sliding it in and
just letting it run and making copies
this was actual
um i had to make photocopies of receipts
so
i was in there a good 20 minutes before
i spent
um the whole five dollars but this is
what i mean
i can't just slide these through a
feeder because they're receipts you know
they have to
one at a time on the scan tray so
i was in there good 20 minutes and after
that i go to put my
um gosh i look my head looks so small
this one seems still kind of normal to
me come up here look normal
anyway so so yeah it didn't really hit
okay okay hold on whoa whoa whoa whoa
what was that my debit card in there
and i'm reading how to do it and a young
woman probably
early 20s late teens maybe even a middle
teenager i don't know i don't try to
guess age it doesn't matter to me
anyway she says um you look or
may i help you you look confused
excuse me i don't understand and she
goes well it seems to me like you might
need some help and i go i don't
need any help i'm doing just fine and
she goes well you look confused
i said well now i'm confused and she
goes well let me help you and i go okay
please tell me
why you think i looked confused when i'm
reading how to work something
because you look confused you look
confused all the time lady
i would much rather read it for myself
before i go ask
skipping ahead feels so heavy skipping
ahead you know
it is a warning saying that if i
have a car in
i'm a resident of the state of
washington my car has to be licensed in
washington however my business license
is in oregon and because my business
license
is in oregon i lease my car
in oregon so that being said
they should have run the plates before
they leave a warning on my car
when i called the vancouver police
department they
i said you know it is harassment this is
the third time i found one on my car
and she said no it's a courtesy and i
said no
three times if it was somebody else
coming and leaving something on my car
or in the door it'd be solicitation and
harassment
you guys are not above the law anyhow
steve royce every morning you find
examples on the internet that our
civilization is on its death throws
and to social media is a primary driver
hey i do what i can
um i want the behavior to stop uh
they need to run the plates because
they'll find out who i leased the car
from
usually there's like a cluster bunch of
people
you know but everybody kind of knows who
got there first and whatever and there's
two cashiers and then you know we split
off into two lines
well i'm there and then
a little while later a man a white man
comes up
and kind of bullies his way in front of
me like there's two lines or something
and he just like keeps moving forward as
that line goes and i'm like um
as it got to where one person in front
of him i said excuse me
i think i'm ahead of you and he goes
there's always two lines there's always
two lines and he got really mad his face
turned red i said it once
um ed baby building with home mortgage
so yeah
i i'm no longer going to patron
this store thank you
i am so freaking angry right now in
washington
state landlords have to give you 48
hours notice to enter
the reason they have to give you 48
hours notice is so that you have the
opportunity to call and reschedule they
can't just say we're coming in in 48
hours make this allotted time
you have to be able to call and say hey
you have to make a time to do this
that's the reason we have that law
however
my apartment complex the park lane
apartments in vancouver
what are you talking yourself 48 hours
which you know
is normally legit but the reason in
washington state
bert it's the bird it's the bird we're
getting to the crazy parts
every time you hear the bird you know
it's coming that's why it's not so that
they can just give you the notice and
come in
however the possessions end up missing
guess who i'm going for 5 29 pm
and i forgot to include in my letter if
any of my possessions end up missing
uh-oh
guess who i'm going for uh-oh
i have missed a day of work now
telephone number to which the tenant
make
because it's a rare oh here we go copy
with some person here we go
age and discretion oh [ __ ] and
sending a copy through the mail
addressed to the person entitled thereto
at his or her place of residence
thank you tracy g resident
i'm angry i'm distraught this is
affecting my mental health
i'm having trouble driving there's no
way i can focus on getting passengers
anywhere safely
there's no way i can keep not run over
a pedestrian because they're everywhere
in portland
there's no way i can be nice to my
fellow drivers while sitting at the hub
at the airport
[Music]
i'm frustrated i'm angry and scared
i'm about ready to go get out of hell
[Music]
this is not supposed to happen
do you know why i wish for everybody
peace love and joy
[Music]
because it's a rare gift for me
[Music]
blessed me from tracy g
peace love and joy
hey this is pcg and i feel like all i've
done is complained lately
and most of the time like i like to keep
things positive
but today at the grocery outlet um i
asked for help finding stink pretties
air freshener and anti-bacterial spray
similar to lysol
and um
lady grab my control
i felt the need to switch counselors
and so i've been shopping around and
shopping around and i thought oh i found
a native american counselor this will be
great
i called her and we discussed things and
i told her about my anxiety and i wanted
to
i needed ongoing mental health
counseling um
because a borderline personality
disorder
post-traumatic stress disorder due to
um early childhood trauma and repetitive
habitual
abuse even as an adult so
um i have a few things and i have
a couple of muscle disorders that make
me depressed sometimes
and i need a counselor when i found one
and i thought oh great i got somebody
i can learn how to communicate with my
daughter better we'll be okay
right okay so
i go in today i'm paying out of pocket
because i figure okay if i pay maybe
i'll get a better counselor right
no i go in and she starts asking me all
of this
money about my finances and things and
i'm like dude if i would have this
paperwork before i could have that all
filled out
and i wouldn't be stressing i don't know
you didn't tell me to bring any of that
in with me how am i supposed to know i
need income verification
you didn't tell me any of this stuff
that i needed because i'm paying cash i
shouldn't have to do low income
paperwork
anyways so i'm panicking about that and
i'm telling her that i'm panicking
this woman says i can cure that
i have the cure for your panic
if this woman had the [ __ ] cure for
panic
don't you think that somebody would
be making some money off that
if this woman had the cure for panic
somebody would be making money off of
that so she tells me she has the cure
and she's going to cure me oh no and i'm
panicking because of this financial
thing
and so she says this and i said no you
do not have the cure
if you did nobody would ever panic ever
again
in the whole world and she goes
well anyhow so then we get done with
that part and i finally get okay
and then we're doing the rest the other
paperwork and she's asking me some
questions
and i'm trying to give her an answer and
i go home i'm trying to get there
and i don't even get two words out of my
mouth and she cuts me off with another
question
dude dude
dude we've been we've been tracking this
we've been following it
she's getting worse and worse
and [ __ ] worse
worse and worse and worse
going oh that i'm like wait i need to
answer that can i answer that question
first
this went on for about eight questions
in a row rapid fire and i was like dude
i need you to let me answer questions
and then she's like well i need you to
understand my background i have
a book do you want to learn more about
me and i'm like i didn't come here and
pay money
to listen to you and your history i'm
here for my counseling
i'm not here to listen to your backstory
and she's like
oh i'm sorry but i think it would help
you understand me better and i said
no it won't i'm here for you
to help me i'm not here to read your
story i'm not paying you by the hour to
read your book
about you and i started panicking and
she's like oh
i'm sorry i'm so sorry and i'm like no
you're not you're still doing it how are
you a professional
this is my freaking field of expertise
and you're sitting there trying to tell
me you know what you're doing
ah
[Music]
so i'm gonna go in and get my money back
i would suggest that if you don't have
any problems and you just want to go in
and pretend everything's fine and do
some breathing techniques
and she'll tell you she has a cure that
you go ahead and go see
cynthia olivier it's from it's spelled
cynthia oliver but i guess it's cynthia
olivier
anyway um she is with four
directions counseling in vancouver
washington
and um i don't recommend her to anybody
who has real serious mental illness
okay lady
dude are those cops
what's going on here
[ __ ] hold on
which should never happen the landlords
are calling because they
don't want us here and then the police
come
and then the police knock and keep
knocking and get more and more
aggressive
and then and then and then referring to
a previous case
just outside in front of the public
of everybody so that's not that
infringes on the rights of the person
that was arrested that day
yep that's true
we're allowed to have panic attacks
we're allowed to live our lives they are
not allowed to keep harassing us
how many times do police and people need
to be here
we do argue by the way this is nobody's
business we're not
fighting we're arguing we're not
breaking any laws
we're not breaking any laws we're not
hurting anybody
there is we're not even it's not even
we're not the ones playing music
until three in the morning when i report
these guys
you need to stop coming and harassing us
when i report these guys for having
their music on at two or three in the
morning nothing happens so you know what
and then we have a heated discussion
because during the day
during the day when it's noise a lot
when noise is allotted
together you guys are working as a team
oh you're just bless your ever loving
heart
thank you for coming to check on me
because i'm not a grown woman
so whoever she's with daughter i don't
know roommate whatever started
fighting with each other they called the
cops
and now they're working together against
the cops am i correct
it's really not appropriate to continue
to slam and these these are the
these are the maintenance people that
are constantly harassing banging on the
doors that i have recordings
coming in illegally and these are the
people
and you guys telling us they're not
breaking any laws
emily's her daughter yeah it was 529
lawyers says they're breaking laws
they've had to pay fines for this
and yet you guys will come out here just
because we're having a heated discussion
our balcony dude you work for the
management you're not allowed to film up
here dude that's even in the contract
yeah you can't it says in our lease that
you're not supposed to do that
in fact i reported it i reported it when
david did it and he got in trouble for
it
so continue to record record us on our
private balcony
okay well then tell these guys to keep
their [ __ ] down and tell them to quit
fighting and kicking so they're
screaming and bothering people on their
balcony
they call the cops because people are
worried and now they're teaming up
against the cops and saying it's
perfectly normal to scream at the top of
your lungs on the balcony am i correct
each other out and having crack pipes
out there
and smoking their cigarettes under here
we report that all the time nobody comes
and says [ __ ] to them
nobody comes in so all you do is sit
here and harass us over and over and
over and over
and sit down there and yell at us like
this and it's getting old
just because we have a panic attack this
is and then you antagonize it and call
the police
that is illegal it's false rewarding
telling us to keep it down when we have
panic attacks
is illegal it's against the americans
with disabilities act legally it's the
first sentence of the americans with
disabilities act that you're supposed to
treat us differently and you're not
they're busting out the americans with
disability act because they have
panic attacks
so you need to stop you need to stop
harassing
but you are when you come over here and
you stand outside the door with your ear
upside the door
mike and i open the door and you fall in
and i got video of it
lawyer has it lawyer has it 29 when i
locked the door and i was buck ass
naked and i was buck ass naked oh it's
it's happening
you came in here to see my kid naked
what the [ __ ] i lost the door i lost
that's why they paid me the hundred
dollars dude
because you were illegal what you do is
illegal
getting into the mailboxes having a key
to the mailbox is illegal
getting into my mail is illegal
oh it don't matter i called the p i
called the post office investigators
and they said what you do is a federal
offense
it's a felony you're not supposed to
have a copy of my mailbox
we have a copy of our mailbox key while
we're still living here
that's not legal
i have video of them in the mailboxes
it's a federal offense
and the person that they were in the
mailbox for was still still currently i
talked to the federal investigator
the inspector george
is the federal investigator and you're
full of crap
holy [ __ ] what's happening
it's getting worse it is getting worse
and worse and worse
everything they do is illegal reporting
us to the cop because we have
mental health is not legal it's not
but as my grandbabies the
well i call them baby grands because
they are
um they're grand to me and um
blessed be
so grateful that i have kept video
record
and written documentation of almost
everything to do
with the behavior of the neighbors
i'm sorry she's building handicapped
through so
much with the landlords she's pulled out
in order to keep such diligent records
again
but i'm so glad i it's illegal oh my
god i hate it but this is where i'm
at
i'm still recovering a bit from surgery
so all of this um
oh whoops i almost showed a areola
it's illegal with the nipple but the
ariel is still legal federally
anyhow i'm still recovering see look how
nicely that version
is in this car is feeling it's sort of
itching finally which means it's healing
which is a beautiful thing
um excuse me it was a ventral hernia
caused by excuse me from when i was
extremely
obese it was a
ball like a fat cyst
but because i hyperventilate when i have
panic attacks
it was constantly pushing and pushing
and pounding and pounding on the ventral
wall
which is the muscle that protects the
lower part
it's the upper abdomen they have upper
abdominal muscles
it's these right here you know what i
mean i don't need to show you about the
upper abdominal
abdominal muscles anyways those that
protect the rib
the lower rib cage and the lower part of
the lungs and the stomach
and you know constantly pounding because
the diaphragm moving up and down up and
down up and down so
it kind of blew its way through when i
had
when i was plays and it had that
semi-stroke thing and was
constantly having to compensate from
this side being paralyzed to using this
side
and then the kundalini yoga because i
had to
learn to coordinate both sides together
again
so i'm recovering from that if i was
having to go to court
with these people plus the fact that i
am only
i am non-confrontational i react
to other people coming to me
i don't even interact with people
outside of
my home i respond
to people like the automatic response
people say good morning good morning
well i'm trying to
retrain myself not to smile every time
because i'm not happy every time and i
don't want to pretend to be anymore
which i would had to be from the time i
was small
doing pageants and things like that so
i'm trying to
unlearn what i know to be true
and it's one of the hardest things ever
because
everything in my life is an unlearning
right now
the racism from my family is a constant
thing
i have to constantly remind myself that
i'm part native american i'm more native
american than i am white
and that's a hard one because then my
whole family
on my mother's side aside from my mother
is welcome to america and now speak
english
that kind of white people who are
actually native
don't understand it's like
being freaking hitler and killing off
jews when he was half
jewish
my whole life as a bunch of hypocrites i
might as well just move into a soapbox
live in a soapbox that way if i feel
high on the horse i can just stand upon
it
and if i feel like caging myself in i
can just climb inside
like a turtle carrying my hole around
people laugh like i'm kidding
my truth is funny to other people my
suffering
my tagline i learned from my abusive
husband as you laugh like i'm kidding
but he'd say it with that sociopathic
look
you laugh oh no i think i'm kidding
oh no or you laugh like you know i'm
kidding
and i've learned to do it i have
borderline personality disorder i can do
it quite well
i can live quite well i can cut off my
emotions quite well
but i don't like getting to that point
because when i get to that point
it eats at my soul
i'm learning i've learned how to be
authentic and i'm learning how to be
more and more authentic every day
so any kind of lying anything that goes
against my soul now
brushes me i used to pray for the eyes
of christ and i warn everybody don't do
that because you'll get them
if you're really open and receptive
you'll get them the thing about me
though is i've always had them i never
had to pray for them i've always felt
i've always been told i feel too much i
laugh too hard
i sing too loud
imagine if i haven't tried to curb
myself exactly how out of control i
would be in history all i can need to be
in an asylum
part of me is grateful it was whipped
out of me but part of me is horrible at
it because i always had to raise my kids
do as i say not as i do
sorry jj going a little late and it was
beating him to me and it's hard for me
to unlearn it
not an excuse to keep doing it but still
a reason
[Music]
so i rambled off on this rant because
i'm having ptsd
going in and out of reliving all of the
stuff with the neighbors and the
violence with their dog coming into my
apartment and snapping at my daughter's
dog
and the confrontations from this woman
who
shoulder buffs me in the hallway and
when i called the police and say she
threatened to kick my ass they tell me
no crime has been committed and to take
it up with my landlords
well i have a mental illness so taking
it up with people is hard
and then mental illness is exacerbated
by being poisoned see i used to be
a very strong independent woman asked
people that knew me
before 2015.
ask almost anybody that actually knew me
i was strong and independent whether
they liked me or not i was still strong
and independent and very self-assured
i knew who i was i didn't know what i
wanted i didn't know how to be a good
parent i was always looking to better
myself
but i was very sure of who i was my
self-esteem
has always been high because why i'm
worthwhile why
just doesn't see me and that's
frustrating
my daughter my daryl emily is teaching
me to voice who i
am without fear well that kind of scares
me
because voicing who i am without fear
there's risks and fallout
tact is never something i've learned but
i have learned how to shut up
smile and look pretty i don't like that
side of me
so i don't know why i needed a rant but
i had to vent
somewhere and i guess this was a good
place and i couldn't sit down in
studio because when i sat in the studio
all i kept doing was thinking about this
restraining order [ __ ]
because i got to get everything in
chronological order and you know
before 2015 asked my professors
i was a research i would research stuff
to the point
that my ocd would get me that i would
throw away
an entire quarter's worth of work
and redo it in a week because i wasn't
satisfied with
any of it and i'd even change the entire
thesis
and i'd still manage to get a 4.0 or
better
now i can barely remember things and i
get my dates flip-flopped and when i
want to say clark county because i lived
in college county for so long i keep
saying collets